- Here are five things
you probably need to hear.
Number one,
not everything that happens
to you is your fault,
but everything that happens
to you is your responsibility.
Right after that you
might think to yourself
everything is my responsibility.
How is everything that happens
to me my responsibility?
I can't possibly account
for every little thing
that life throws my way,
the chaos, the triumph
and if something goes wrong,
which it inevitably will.
Am I supposed to blame myself?
Because I was responsible
for having that thing not go wrong.
That's not really what
I'm getting at here,
because for most of us,
our domain of influence is fairly small.
We usually go to similar places,
we see similar people,
we do similar activities
as we do most days.
And occasionally we step outside the norm
and we experience new
people, places and things
to freshen things up.
And along the way,
we'll be put in situations
that we don't like,
situations that make us
feel uncomfortable or angry.
We'll talk to people
that we think are idiots.
And occasionally we'll be blindsided
by tragedy or misfortune.
I don't have to tell
you what life is like.
Life is spicy, but if it is in our life,
it is our responsibility to figure out
what we're going to do about it.
Because who else's responsibility is it?
Who else is responsible
for your physical fitness,
your mental health, your social life?
Who else is responsible
for the types of people
that you're inviting into your life?
The type of reaction that you have
when something doesn't go your way.
When you break it down like this,
it's really hard to think of anything
that's not your responsibility.
Anything that you would realistically do,
interact with, experience.
Aren't you tired of
delegating the responsibility
of your own flourishing onto other people?
It's probably time that
you have some confidence
in your ability to make
decisions for yourself.
To assume responsibility over
the outcomes of your life,
regardless of whose fault it may be.
Because at the end of
the day, it affects you.
So what are you gonna do about it?
Number two, life gets easier
when you're on your own side.
If you love yourself first and
treat yourself with respect
you'll have more love to give.
When you dislike yourself
and treat yourself poorly,
then you'll start to subliminally
feel unlikable and worthless.
And if this is your default mode of being,
if you continue to treat yourself poorly,
if you don't like yourself very much,
then every single
interaction that you have
with every single person in
your life will be tainted
with the need to solve
this inherent problem.
Because we need to feel
loved and accepted.
And if you starve yourself
of your own approval
off the get go,
then every interaction
that we have with people
will be trying to gain that approval back.
You'll start to rely
heavily on other people
to make you feel validated
and worth something.
And if you do this long enough
you'll start to lean on
this external validation
like a crutch, addicted to compliments,
constantly searching for
validation and approval.
You'll start to wear clothes
that you don't necessarily like
but you think you're gonna get
a lot of compliments on it.
You think you're being kind of
bold and brash by wearing it.
And when you don't get that attention
that you so desperately require,
you'll start to build resentment.
You'll start to feel butt hurt.
You'll be kind of passive
aggressive for no reason
because they owe you something, right?
Every interaction that
you have is an exchange,
you're nice to people,
you compliment people,
just so that you can be complimented back.
And if people treat you poorly,
holy smokes, that ruins your day.
Because when a person doesn't just not
return your compliment
but they're rude to you,
they become public enemy number one.
Because you've conditioned yourself
to place your entire sense of self-worth
in the hands of other people.
But at the end of the day,
what you think other people
owe you, you owe to yourself.
If you start treating
yourself like somebody
that you genuinely care
about and want the best for,
if you start acting as if
you're on your own side
then it will change every
single aspect of your life.
It will change the way
you walk into a room.
It will change the way that
you interact with other people.
It will change the clothes that you wear,
the way that you speak,
and every decision that you make.
when you treat yourself with
respect and you love yourself
then you will actually be
able to give compliments
without expecting any in return.
You will actually have
the ability to be generous
with your time, with your
attention, with your resources
because you genuinely want to,
it comes from a place of abundance.
Treating yourself with respect,
just as a ridiculous ROI.
Number three, nobody owes you anything.
You are not entitled to any job position,
any lifestyle, any relationship.
Just because you have
big muscles and workout
doesn't mean you're entitled
to a hot girlfriend.
Maybe your personality is the equivalent
of a wet sock or a dirty diaper.
Just because you have a business degree
from a Community College,
doesn't mean that you're entitled
to be on the board of directors.
Even if your business
degree is from Harvard
or some other prestigious school,
you're still not entitled to anything.
The type of person who walks around
like the world owes them something,
usually comes from a place of lack.
And they're usually very ungrateful
when they get the thing that
they think they deserve.
And they're white-hot and
vengeful when they don't get it.
The type of person who thinks this way
usually has a giant ego.
They have an idea of themselves
that is disconnected
from reality in some way.
They probably have some
delusion of grandeur
where they want to appear on the surface
that they're better
than they actually are.
But as I've covered in
previous videos, ego is brutal.
It distorts you from the truth,
it stunts growth,
ego is far more concerned
with being somebody
rather than doing something.
And if you followed step two
and started treating
yourself like somebody
you're responsible for helping,
which is kind of a direct
quote from Jordan Peterson,
then you wouldn't require others
to give you things to make you feel whole.
You'll start to want certain positions
because of a genuine confidence
that you could add value.
So instead of chasing status,
work on developing competence,
focus on the craft, not the corner office.
Because 99 times out of a hundred,
your work will speak for itself.
Number four, communism has
failed every time it was tried.
Number five, it's going to be okay.
I don't know what you're
going through right now.
You could be having a
very great time in life.
It could be, you know
probably the best time
that you've ever had.
You might feel energetic and optimistic
and like everywhere you go,
there's a song singing behind you,
a song singing behind you,
there's a background track,
cinematic score elevating
all of your steps,
butterflies everywhere.
But for a lot of people, I know
that's indeed not the case.
I get the feeling that
there's a lot of people
watching the video that
are in a very rough place.
Maybe they're going through something
that is just like
incomprehensibly, tragic, you know.
Life has a habit of doing
that to a lot of people.
I know it's hard to think about,
it's hard to imagine that
things could be better for you.
And sometimes it's not
better for a little while
but life's kinda weird
because it seems like every
dark period that I've ever had
in my life has always turned into a period
where I looked back and I never
regretted the dark period.
Like there was always so much to learn
in those periods of darkness.
So much to learn about
yourself, about other people.
And sometimes those
realizations about other people
are that people can be
pretty terrible. (laughs)
But I think that if you have
compassion for yourself,
if you have compassion for others,
if you realize that at the end of the day
you're still responsible
for your own happiness,
regardless of whose fault
your current happiness levels might be.
You're still responsible
for making something of it
and there is always
something to be made from it.
As long as you're voluntarily willing
to confront whatever your situation is in
with humility and perseverance,
something good always comes from it
and that's been my experience.
The only time something
good doesn't come from it
is if you bury your head
in the sand and give up.
But even then,
I feel like we're given
countless second chances in life.
So if you are currently
burying your head in the sand,
consider taking your head out of the sand,
looking around dusting yourself off
and getting back on the grind.
Because at the end of the day,
if you are willing to stick with it,
things will be okay,
they always will be okay.
Even if you're not okay, that's okay too.
It's gonna be okay.
I just want to give a
big thank you to Audible
for sponsoring this video.
Guys, I really want to
recommend an audio book
and that audio book is
"Make Your Bed" by William H. McRaven.
The book was written by a
retired U.S. Navy Admiral
and it really helps shift your mindset
into assuming responsibility
over the outcomes of your life.
So I really recommend the read.
It's super short and you
could bang it out in one day
very easily as you're cleaning your house.
And for those of you who
don't know about Audible,
it is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
and audiobooks all in one place.
If you're even remotely
interested in self-improvement,
that's just a wild guess that you are,
and you want to enrich your life
by enriching the ideas
that are bouncing around
inside your head, then Audible
is honestly a no brainer.
As an audible member, every single month,
you receive one credit which you can spend
on any audiobook of your
choice regardless of cost.
And you get to keep
that audio book forever.
If you ever cancel your subscription
for any reason, at any point,
you still keep your entire
library of audiobooks.
Audible members also get access
to a rapidly expanding
catalog of Audible originals,
Podcasts, and Exclusive Series.
So if you're interested in
joining me in becoming big brain
and filling your brain with the best ideas
on the face of the earth,
then if you use my link
in the description below,
you get a 30 day free trial.
Just click the link,
head on over to audible.com/betterideas,
or you can even text
betterideas to 500-500.
So yeah, take advantage of that link
or just text betterideas to 500-500.
Thanks again to Audible
for sponsoring this video.
If you enjoyed this video,
if you got something out of it
and you said this was a good video
thank you for that, Joey.
I appreciate you,
I appreciate the work you're doing.
And I just appreciate us,
I appreciate the audience members
and I appreciate living
life to its fullest.
Then go ahead and actually
click the like button
because when you click the like button,
it actually helps me out a ton
because it helps the video rank better.
It helps push the video into
other people's homepages,.
helping them out, helping me out.
It's just a circle of love and life.
And it's a win-win for everybody.
And if you're lurking
here, consider subscribing
and helping my really sad Instagram,
instagram.com/betterideas
get more followers
because it's very sad.
Like we have 1.7 million strong here.
The YouTube community is just unreal
but our Instagram's sad.
So if you're on Instagram anyways
and you want to help the Better Ideas army
spread its wings like,
I can't think of an analogy,
spread its wings like
a flying squirrel do that.
I was gonna say a naked mole-rat,
but that would be,
imagine like a naked
mole-rat that could fly,
but yeah just help us do that.
Do whatever you want I don't care.